بدلا من ان تسعى حركه طالبان لتقني على
العالم بالاعتراف بحكومتها المسيطره في
افغانستان عفوا تستمر باتخاذ خطوات تعقد
مسارها وتزيد من عزلتها الدوليه اذا اعلنت
حكومه طالبان ان الجامعات الافغانيه باتت
محظوره لاجل غير مسمى على الفتيات
المحرومات اصلا من التعليم الثانوي منذ
وصول الحركه الى الحكم وزير التعليم
العالي في حكومه طالبان ندى محمد نديم قال
في رساله موجهه الى كل الجامعات الحكوميه
والخاصه ابلغكم جميعا بتنفيذ الامر
المذكور بوقف تعليم الاناث حتى اشعر اخر
وسرعان ملبى مسلحول حركه الامر الحكومي
بمنعهم اليوم مئات الشابات من دخول حرام
جامعات افغانيه امر سدد ضربه اخرى لحقوق
الانسان في هذا البلد بدورها رده بعض
الجامعات في افغانستان الطالبات ومنعتهن
من الدخول اليوم عقب القرار
فقالتشيستا وهي تدرس اداره الاعمال في
جامعه خاصه بكابول ذهبنا الى الجامعه وكان
رجال طالبان عند البوابه واخبرونا انه
يحضر علينا دخول الجامعه حتى اشعار اخر
وكما نرى الفتيات
تبكي
[موسيقى]
خطوه طالبان اثارت انتقادات دوليه واسعه
اذا عبرت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان
لها عن استغرابها واسفها لقرار حكومه
تصريف الاعمال الافغانيه بمنع الفتيات من
حق التعليم الجامعي واضافت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان الرياض تدعو حكومه تصريف
الاعمال الافغانيه للتراجع عن القرار
واعتبرته امرا يتنافى مع اعطاء المراه
حقوقها اما البيت الابيض فقال ان الولايات
المتحده على اتصال بالحلفاء حول قرار
طالبان وذكرت المتحدثه باسمي مجلس الامن
القومي ادريان واتسون في بيان ان الولايات
المتحده تدين قرار طالبان الذي لا يمكن
الدفاع عنه بمنع الافغانيات من تلقي
تعليمات من جهتها اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا لينابير بوك ان حكومه
الطالبان قررت تدمير مستقبل افغانستان
بحضر التعليم الجامعي على النساء وكتبت في
تغريده بتدمير مستقبل البنات والنساء في
افغانستان تكون ط قررت تدمير مستقبل بلدها
بدورها او بدوره ابدى الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيرش قلقه العميق ازاء
قرار طالبان داعيا الحركه الى ضمان
المساواه في الحصول على التعليم على كل
المستويات
[موسيقى]